hello guys I'm Ryan Wright we're gonna
be checking out a video called Grayson
earth one the series premiere this video
has gotten a lot of attention on a lot
of big movie sites I've been dying to
watch Oh Nightwing hunt for Oracle one
of the first graphic novels I ever
picked up and bought I [ __ ] love this
comic book so Nightwing is awesome for
you guys who don't know Nightwing is
he's Dick Grayson Batman's dick becomes
Nightwing in Bludhaven blüdhaven I
forget I don't pronounce it I don't know
much about the series but I've been
dying to watch it fan made IndieGoGo
project if it's good I'm gonna
contribute my dollars how about you
Katie for sure's all
this is 16 minutes by the way
I want that to be me thing film you know
that does look like it could be it
I wish we just saw the whole performance
what really like the doesn't have to
learn from each other never like you
don't have to come inside with me if you
don't want to god me this far and thank
you but I have to do this hey Terry
he's kinda mine's really crow
I'm open
yeah if that is the main character
it really water to capture that song I
wonder where they shot this thing
liver function defined in a perfect plan
in an assembly
toxicity dangerous and you not tyrunt
you should much already administered me
as presents
very
I always considered the tune to be how
this make you feel
don't you agree
countless like even campy oh [ __ ] I
really didn't want her to die
yeah I had so much invested yeah
nice that's pretty cool that's pretty
cool
boobies to go
the fries mm-hmm - Richard oh look it's
got try to rape you
this
thirty or forty girls missing
readings
that's how we met
nice
see what nothing
you came here for me
she's Filipino I had to tell
I'll use fire recording
well
there's something else on the news the
cops fear
you can grieve enough great
how many
you see
it's not
was potential right
you only said much it's me
okay make may I provide my comments
first please I thought it was awesome
you know super captivated the whole time
I thought the casting choices were
really fun okay the guy was really
interesting for me to watch I want to be
a part of it I think you could I think
you could be a part of it your acting
style seems good enough to be in it I
had a hard time readjusting to all the
changes that I'm a previously known from
Batman this is clearly dick racing
before he met Batman but I was like he
wasn't like okay but this is a Nightwing
story he was Robin first then he
graduated and became Nightwing let it go
is hard to because also you was like
taken in by Bruce Wayne when he was
young when his parents died so this is a
reimagining it's a total reimagining but
there's like no preparation for my mind
to it just to that I was like wait a
minute what what he's in a [ __ ] email
looking band and Batman's like I'm
watching you and he's what are you used
to the whole time it was kind of but he
could still know Bruce Wayne but not
know Batman right well in the comics he
like lives of Bruce Wayne for a while
and you know you know a lot of different
variations but he usually becomes Robin
not too long after living with Bruce
Wayne if I can like readjust my feelings
and look at it for just what it is
I think it's a really good made indie
project I'll say that for an indie
project that's really good I mean it has
some of its technical issues where
you're like okay this kind of does feel
like amateur this kind of does feel like
a student film for the most part a guy
who was cast as Dick Grayson was good
the action I thought could have been a
little bit better the fight scenes since
you know we have movies like the raid
now and everything that you know like
there's a great level of capacity actor
is I really liked how it was shocked
though I was interested to see the
cinematography if that was really solid
I enjoyed that a lot I enjoyed the
culture of the world then yes
created I enjoyed the aesthetic okay of
the world that was created it was smoky
but it was also like sort of these you
know glow be like lights in the
background I thought was all very
interesting I just don't usually see it
I guess that's what I'm saying
in that big Hollywood movies I don't see
anything this artistic it's a lot to
readjust to though if you already cuz
like and the reason why I'm pointing
that out is because I'm not one of those
people ever who's like oh it's different
from the comics it's different from the
book but it's very different very
different and plenty of people know the
story even if they're not that into
comics like a lot of them will be aware
of the Robbins story there's a lot of
people know Robin a lot of people don't
know Nightwing is and the comics like
Barbara Gordon is she's a Oracle at that
point and she's supposed to be
handicapped so yeah it was just a lot
for my brain to wrap itself around but
when I look back on it it was shot well
it had a different type of gritty vibe
because anytime it's got them or even
Bludhaven my short city this is but
whenever it's like the Batman world
there's always gonna be some type of
grittiness to it they weren't capable
enough to bring a different kind of
grittiness to it yeah I like that my
favorite moment was when Batman showed
up I was so excited you could see I mean
I would just when you see just like that
outline yeah right behind in the
silhouette yeah and you see the bad ears
long cuz I didn't know I didn't know
that Batman was gonna be this nice so
that was really exciting and the chick
who plays Barbara Gordon she's [ __ ]
good to look at yeah she makes this
video better
she's hope that all the ladies were
lovely ladies uh most of the slave girls
now
I would like to see some good lady
fighting I hope that's coming up in next
episodes cuz there was some like
trickery you know she got out of her
cause she like took a good punch but I
want to see some yeah hand hand I want
to see better-looking girls that have
been kidnapped
that's a weird well I just think you're
gonna get a bunch of girls usually get
like really good looking ones
there are there are organ that it's it's
mr. freeze he's freezing their organs
yeah oh no I totally get everything to
do it's not like but if you're gonna
kill your all you might as well make
sure she's a really pretty why that's
like the opposite of what you ever think
you
you would want to Katie you just don't
get how guys I think I think all
everyone in this world is like
good-looking I think like that's just
part of like movies is like in general
everyone is like young and good-looking
in this yes
I'm wondering how they found this main
guy because he obviously like is a
pretty good musician like if they found
him as a musician and then brought him
in as an actor if they found him as an
actor and then they were like oh my god
man you you're like in a band that's
awesome let's use that oh and you could
fight too this is exactly what we're
looking for always wanted that's part of
the reason why I was thinking like what
city is this in because like I probably
local projects and I'm thinking like
what city is this like talent in these
locations and this Lake said oh there's
a lot of things about it that I did have
problems with it I feel like it did lack
in life actually like they're obviously
going for the darkness and everything
which is fine it's the Batman where it's
the bat world at the same time I'm like
it seems kind of like forced and heavy
drama I didn't really care about anyone
in this story like yeah I didn't really
care about anyone oh I didn't really
find them that not unlikable but not
necessarily likable I think it has a lot
of potential I think you could be like a
really good CW show yeah that's what it
can be it can be like a CW show like
flash arrow but you know with a better
budget that's the thing it's like I know
this is all personally fun this is all
privately funded Holy Smoke
so this is awesome for being personally
funded ya know for that purpose I
respect it a lot for what they were able
to accomplish I respect it I think with
a budget yes it could be a lot better
but are the filmmakers capable of making
it a lot better cuz I would love to see
a Nightwing series but at the same time
the changes they made I'm not the
biggest fan of when the comics at least
from what I've read yeah he's he's a cop
by day and Nightwing at night and I find
that more interesting yeah like I would
have preferred to see a story straight
up about Nightwing but he was Robin
already and everything like that's way
more intriguing to me than this lonely
emo guy who's in a band okay because of
fighting skills apparently no I think we
need to see how it pans out you know I'm
deaf
only gonna watch another episode well
yeah what's up to is out you know maybe
some of your hesitations maybe
maybe they'll pull you in slowly Hart
strand by Hart strand
they'll just wrap you in the warm
embrace of indie art comic Oh studio in
me studios it has a great potential it
does like even with its storyline that
you know like with all the changes if I
just learned it except this is a lot of
changes to accept but if I just learn to
go with it I think it does have a lot of
great potential it could be something I
could see on a network I think you could
even be darker like I think it could be
more gritty with a weird kind of sense
of humor to it that's what I love about
the whole bat world is that like there
is a weird dark sense of humor about it
this just seems straightforward like you
know like when you see student
filmmakers like I'm gonna make it an
impactful dark film like I felt that at
times like trying to make it moving I
felt a lot of trying not full
accomplishment with that in mind I still
feel that if it does get picked up I
would gladly check out and check it out
if it got picked up for a series and I'm
all on board I find it super fun I do
hope I'm super enjoying the main
character the females I have not been
captivated by they're just not as
dynamic and I'd be excited to like see a
little more dynamic way there but other
than that I'm like totally gonna watch
the next episode and lastly I'll say I
haven't gave him the main actor enough
enough credit because he does do a good
job like yes he doesn't have a lot of
background give me a moment where she
like does this you know and yeah you
know it's just like whatever that moment
was or he was like he didn't know how to
receive yeah the actor was really good
he provided a lot of depth for someone
we don't wanna say yeah good job done
if Nightwing does get picked up and
you're gonna keep it with this storyline
keep it for sure they're listening to my
instructions okay okay yeah so please hi
I'm in charge of where Nightwing goes
you're feeling there Batman and I'm
Robin
just kind of yeah and I'm wearing a
Superman shoes to piss off anyone who's
watching this video anyway guys thanks
for tuning in with us if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects katie has a channel too she
just ordered a comic book a graphic
novel you know why because she's gonna
start up graphic novel reviews.people so
check out her channel she has some fun
stuff on there already and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and signing off good video yeah good
video we did good yeah I felt like we
brought the right amount of like
entertaining stupidness yeah yeah do you
think he had enough sex jokes I don't
think it had any sex jokes god damn it
you know a lot more sex jokes if that's
pretty earth standard I just I just
don't think anything is funny unless
there's a sex tape it just going out now